es ist das größte radioteleskop der welt
und jetzt steht es kurz vor dem beginn
seines regulären betriebs mit hilfe des
500 meter aperture circle radioteleskop
kurz was wollen die chinesen
bahnbrechende entdeckungen machen es
geht nicht nur um die erforschung von
gravitationswellen sondern auch um die
suche nach außerirdischem leben und es
wurden schon die ersten entdeckungen in
der testphase gemacht klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science abonniert den kanal
und activity klocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen jahr 2016 wurde der bau des
größten radioteleskops 500 meter m pages
ferkel radioteleskop kurz fast beendet
und es wurde eröffnet für die testphase
das ganze projekt waren nicht ohne für
den bau des teleskops wurden mehr als
8000 einwohner umgesiedelt in china ist
dass er offenbar kein problem
dafür verlief der bau selbst der
rekordzeit im wesentlichen war das
teleskop in nur fünf jahren
fertiggestellt seit drei jahren läuft
nun die feinjustierung doch auch hier
stehe man nun kurz vor der finalisierung
mit dem riesenteleskop in china zehn bis
zwanzig jahre lang weltweit führend
bleiben auf chinesisch heißt es feiern
so viel wie himmels auge ist übertrumpft
den bisherigen rekordhalter arecibo in
den usa mit 200 metern und das ist
erheblich die schüssel vom fast misst
stolze 500 meter im durchmesser und
damit sollen in den kommenden jahren
spektakuläre entdeckungen gemacht werden
sind besteht aus 4450 3 gegen einzel
paneelen und bedeckt eine gigantische
fläche von mehr als 196 1349 anhalt
quadratmetern ein himmels ausschnitt von
bis zu 40 grad kann von der schüssel
abgedeckt werden möglich wird das durch
stellmotoren die die form der antenne
schüssel verändern können möglich
gemacht wird somit nicht nur eine
gleichmäßige kugel hälfte sondern auch
die form eines parabol das sind wirklich
bahnbrechende möglichkeiten insgesamt
160 millionen euro hat das
riesenteleskope kostet doch nach plan
der chinesen wird sich diese investition
nicht nur für die astronomie weltweit
sondern auch für andere forschungsfelder
lohnen seit 2016 wird fast jetzt also
kalibriert und getestet doch der
regulären betrieb
soll nun zeitnah beginnen dann starten
auch die richtigen wissenschaftlichen
bottoms kampagnen unter anderem
beteiligen sich die fast forschungsteams
auch an internationalen kampagnen die
nach außerirdischen suchen
beispielsweise gibt es eine beteiligung
an der sogenannten break zu listen
initiative hier wird im rahmen der
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
wti nach signalen von außerirdischen
gefahrenen die astronomie teams sind
zuversichtlich dass fast hierbei enorm
hilfreich sein könnte das teleskop will
man dafür direkt auf planeten außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems richten mögliche
spuren außerirdischen lebens könnten so
direkt ins visier genommen werden dazu
einer der leitenden wissenschaftler vor
ort zu ming bei der beobachtung von
signalen von himmelskörpern sammeln wir
auch signale die von menschen oder von
außerirdischer intelligenz ausgesendet
werden können dies ist jedoch eine
enorme menge an arbeit doch was sollen
auch viele weitere spannende
erkenntnisse ermöglichen unter anderem
zu schwarzen löchern und
gravitationswellen aber auch dass
wasserstoff vorkommen in weit entfernten
galaxien könnte mit fast erforscht
werden ebenso die zusammensetzung von
exoplaneten nach berichten des
chinesischen staatsfernsehens cctv
wurden in den vergangenen drei jahren
auch schon einige entdeckungen gemacht
demnach konnten bereits in der testphase
knapp 100 schnell rotierende
neutronensterne aufgespürt werden diese
wenn der fachsprache auch als pulsare
bezeichnet hierbei handelt es sich um
stark magnetisierte rotierende
neutronensterne die elektromagnetische
strahlen aussenden
die chinesen sind damit ziemlich happy
und so kommen die letzten abschließenden
untersuchungen zum performance und
technik langsam zum ende dann können
auch fachleute aus dem ausland erstmals
beobachtungszeiten buchen dazu der chef
forscher am fast die lieb für die
weitgehende umstellung sehen wir keine
hürde wir finden bald außerirdische
anklicken anschauen und klicks zum
science und fiction abonnieren dann seid
ihr vielleicht mit als erste dabei wenn
außerirdisches leben entdeckt wird also
bis dann bleibt dran wir fiebern dem
entgegen